the fall of the Berlin Wall and the fall
of the gray-haired leaders of the GDRs
socialist Unity Party of Germany or SED
from one day to the next the reign of
the SED ended it was time to rethink
things should the party continue or
disband one man had been there from the
beginning Gregor geezy a lawyer and a
prominent party member in my invite the
party was founded by rosa luxemburg and
colleague Knecht I said to myself either
be part of it or leave dissolving the
party's not your job the familiar
symbols of SCD socialism were removed
but the party planned to carry on with a
new name and personnel hundreds of
thousands left the party disappointed
but many who once worked with the East
German intelligence service the Stasi
remained Gregor geezee emerged as the
new party leader promising to clean up
he became the chairman of the new party
of democratic socialism the link as the
successor to the SED party the pds of
course had a huge advantage over the
other parties because of its large
strong organizational structures it also
had more financial resources than the
other parties time the PDS joined the
German parliament the bundestag Gregor
geezee remained its leader despite
allegations of Stassi involvement I'm
thanking his mere dad I was concerned
that many people in the GDR would be
left behind during unification for
example society's elite the PDS became a
party to contend with after merging with
a leftist party from the West in 2007 it
gained new popularity and a new name the
left the left made social justice its
platform it demanded a minimum wage it
argued against German military
involvement in foreign countries and
called for the rich to pay higher taxes
the party was especially successful in
eastern Germany but balancing its
communist past with its current platform
was a tightrope walk by zia of times I
did wish I was on the one hand the left
had to make clear that they've changed
on the other hand they still had to
accept old members and function
who remained nostalgic about the old gdr
times fog is undaunted idiots I think
despite constant factional infighting
Gregor geezy was able to hold the party
together but after 25 years he gave up
the party's chairmanship out with minor
hiccup this yet Stein I've helped to
give Germany a widely accepted Left
Party and I've done my part to help
normalize Germany itself and if my party
becomes more normal too then I can be
pretty content than very serious wit and
then Gregor Jesus dream could finally
come true seeing the left become a
coalition partner in the German
government